you're one of if not the most famous
wealthy and powerful people in the world
in your position is difficult to find
people you can trust trust no one not
even yourself not trusting yourself okay
well that's you're saying that jokingly
but is there some trust no one not even
no
one going need an hour just to think
about that and maybe some
drugs and maybe grock to um I mean is
there some aspect of that when just
existing in a world where everybody
wants something from you how hard is it
to exist in that world I'll
survive there's there's a song like that
too I Will Survive will you petrified at
first um okay I forget the rest of the
lyrics but is is there you don't
struggle with this I mean I know you
survive but like there there's ways
petrify is a spell in the Droid tree
what does it do
petrify it it turns it turns the
monsters into stone
oh like literally yeah for like six
seconds well the second there's so much
math in Diablo that breaks my brain it's
like math non-stop I mean really you're
like laughing at it but you don't it can
it can put a huge amount of tension on a
mind yes it can be definitely stressful
at
times well how do you know who you can
trust in work in personal life I mean I
guess you look at somebody's track
record over time and if they've got a
you know I guess you kind of use your
neural net to assess you know someone
and neural Nets don't feel pain you're
in your own that has Consciousness it
might it might feel pain when people
betray
you it can make you know to be frank I
mean i' I've almost never been
betrayed it's very very rare so you know
for what is wor I guess karma be good to
people and they'll be good to you yeah
karma is real are there people you
trust let me edit that question are
there people uh close to you that call
you out in your
[__] um well the xlat form is very
helpful for
that if you're looking for critical
feedback can it push you like into the
extremes more the extremes of thought
make you cynical about human nature in
general I I don't think I will be
cynical in fact I think
um you know I my feeling is that one
should be be you
know never trust a
cynic the reason is that um cynics
excuse their own bad behavior by saying
everyone does
it because they're
cynical so I always be it's a red flag
if someone's a cynic a true cynic yeah
there's a degree of projection there
that's always fun to watch from the
outside and enjoy the well hocy if but
but this is an important point that I
think people who are listening should
bear in mind if if somebody is cynical
meaning that they see bad behavior in
everyone um it's easy for them to excuse
their own bad
behavior by saying that well everyone
does
it that's not
true I most people are kind of medium
good I do wish the people people on X
would be better at seeing the good in
other people's behavior there seems to
be a kind of weight towards seeing the
negative somehow the negative is sexier
interpreting the negative is sexier more
viral I don't know what that is exactly
about human nature I mean I find the
xplatform to be less negative than the
Legacy Media you know I mean if if you
read sort of a sort of conventional
newspapers just it makes you sad yeah
frankly
um whereas I'd say on the X
platform I I mean I really get more
laughs per day on X than everything else
combined from humans you know laughs is
one
thing laughs is it uh overlaps but it's
not necessarily perfectly overlapping
with like Good Vibes and support like um
celebrating others for example not in a
stupid shallow night na way but like in
an awesome like oh something awesome
happened and you celebrate them for it
it's it feels that that is outweighed by
[__] at other people now it's better
than mainstream media but it's still
yeah mainstream media is almost
relentlessly negative about everything
um it's I mean really the conventional
news tries to answer the question what
is the worst thing that I happened on
Earth today MH and it's a big world so
on any given day something bad has
happened and a general ization of that
what is the worst perspective I can take
on a thing that happened so yeah it's I
don't know there's just a strong
negative bias in the news
um I mean I think there what a possible
explanation for this is evolutionary
um where you know bad news historically
would be potentially fatal like this
lion over there or there's some other
tribe that wants to kill you um good
news you know like we found a patch of
berries is nice to have but not
essential